[Applause]
a slump in Sterling panic in the markets
but a calm sense of Confidence from this
man
labor leader who finally believes his
moment has arrived thank you conference
it's great to be here in Liverpool
excitement palpable but Kirsten a
politician still with plenty to prove
tiling away from the left with an eye on
Tory territory on climate change growth
aspiration leveling up brexit economic
responsibility
we are the party of the center ground
once again the political wing of the
British people
that a phrase used by Tony Blair the
last labor leader to win a general
election this a man who thinks he could
win the next using the Tory's current
economic woes to his advantage
I can't go on like this
what we've seen in the past few days has
no precedent
the government has lost control of the
British economy
Rachel Reeves and I have set out a
framework for sound money
we're determined to reduce debt as a
share of our economy telling voters it's
labor not the Tories who can be trusted
on the economy and doing that with a
fresh back-end for business I want to be
crystal clear about this
I'm not just pro-business I want to
partner with business
a new taxpayer-owned company to invest
in renewable energy so we will set up
Great British energy within the first
year of a labor government
a new company that takes advantage of
the opportunities in clean British power
Great British energy will be publicly
owned
a new labor but this by no means a
complete departure the NHS still its
core priority I'm really worried about
how many lives are at risk this winter
if it's a choice between a tax cut for
those earning hundreds of thousands of
pounds labor will always deliver for
rnhs
these no longer just promises from the
party opposite but instead a realistic
pitch for power as in 1945 1964
1997. this is a labor moment and
together with the British people we will
do it thank you conference
a year ago case starmer was being
heckled in the hall now he's been
cheered from the rafters as he declares
that labor is the party of business the
party of aspiration the party of the
center ground he is taking the fight to
the Tories and the labor party is so
different from how it was even a year
ago but he knows too it's going to be a
long journey but what is clear in the
hall is labor finally believed they can
win the next general election honestly
this is the best labor party conference
I've ever been to and I've been to quite
a few and how many have you been to
you've probably been to everyone since
1999 I think is it fair to say that the
public are now looking again at labor
but they still don't necessarily love
labor the public didn't see us as a
future but now they're seeing what the
conservatives have done did you enjoy
that Mr Stormer There's an opportunity
he relished inside this conference Hall
one story
but out here a country facing turbulent
political and economic Times labor now
with a real opportunity to get into
government 12 years out of power is the
tide finally about to turn Beth Rigby
Sky News in Liverpool